c'est à montréal à 92 originaire du
liban immigrés sans papiers sans emploi
rhabillage devenu écrivain acclamé et
traduit en plus de 30 langues
près de dix ans après son arrivée au
canada l'egypte est libre on flingue
heures je suis lundi à new york un
moment donné j'étais sans papiers alors
j'ai décidé de tout quitter
après ne va pas c'est dans la pauvreté à
new york
rawi hage s'est installé à montréal en
le jeune immigrant étudie alors en
beaux-arts et cumul des emplois dans des
restaurants
il a été chauffeur de taxi pendant deux
ans je m'appelle je pris quatre clients
américains qu'il voulait voir des french
gosse
l'ancien chauffeur de taxi s'est mise à
l'écriture sur le tard alors qu'il avait
près de 40 ans à un jour je me suis n'y
crois pas je cuis une petite nouvelle du
crime une nouvelle journée un ami m'a
dit tu as une voix
il faut que tu la détruis son premier
roman écrit en anglais et intitulé deux
niros game connaît un succès fulgurant
traduit en français le livre est
finaliste au prix galère et aux prix
littéraires du gouverneur général
ce livre sur la guerre civile au liban
et critique de la religion
j'accuse religion dans tout le monde
dans tous mes livres
avec le temps je suis devenu de plus en
plus convaincus suis athée sur la foi et
je crois pas que la région est
essentielle pour être une bonne personne
ra brouillage en a terminé avec le taxi
et il vit modestement de sa plume
son livre intitulé le cafard a été
adapté au cinéma et il vient de publier
un quatrième roman déjà la décision de
30 artistes c'est difficile m un
immigrant es artiste c'est un peu la
folie c'est l'option que j'ai pris de
grands risques
et ce quand j'étais têtue ce que je
voulais faire ce que j'ai fait ici
louis philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal